et ce matin nous recevons pierre
marescaux bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes français vous êtes un ancien
journaliste vous vivez à kiev depuis
trois ans avec votre femme qui est
enceinte de plus de huit mois vous avez
fui kiev après avoir passé notamment une
nuit dans le métro aujourd'hui où vous
retrouvez vous êtes vous en sécurité
bonjour à vous merci pour votre
invitation alors oui en effet je me
trouve aujourd'hui en pologne donc après
un périple de plus de 2 3 jours où j'ai
dû quitter donc mon domicile de kiev et
je suis ici donc en sécurité bien sûr
hébergés chez des membres de ma de ma
famille puisque j'avais un peu aussi de
famille ici en pologne est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer vous avez tout
d'abord passer une nuit dans le métro
quelle était l'ambiance et après nous
expliquer ce périple de ce qui a duré
plus de 60 heures
oui alors comme beaucoup d'ukrainiens en
fait j'ai je me suis réfugié dès les
premiers jours de la deûle a dès le
premier jour de l'invasion dans des
abris anti bombes donc qui se trouve un
peu partout dans kiev sous les immeubles
mais aussi dans les stations de métro
donc
au premier jour de l'invasion nous avons
décidé ma femme sa soeur sa mère et moi
de nous réfugier dans une station de
métro à côté de notre domicile puisque
il ya des menaces de bombardements et de
combats à côté de chez nous nous
habituons donc dans le nord de kiev là
où les combats ont été assez important
et nous avons donc passé plus d'une
dizaine d'heures tout d'abord dans cette
station de métro avec
200 300
une craignent un nous avons passé la
nuit là bas et donc
nous sommes repartis ensuite le
lendemain nous avons décidé de partir
vers l'ouest et pourquoi pourquoi vous
avez pris cette décision de quitter qui
est vous aviez une occasion quitter la
ville c'était c'était le bon moment
fallait y aller alors je pense que
c'était la seule occasion qu'on avait en
réalité le lendemain matin si vous
voulez les tanks russes arrivés par la
ville de lisbonne rod par le nord donc
directement sur notre quartier de haut
bologne dans le nord de kiev
et ait en fait j'ai profité d'une petite
accalmie et de la fin du couvre feu donc
après 7 heures du matin pour sortir et
foncez chez moi aller chercher ma
voiture et récupérer donc ma femme sa
soeur et sa mère à la station de métro
et ensuite nous avons traversé kiev
rouler vert vers l'ouest donc sur la
route sur la route de l'ouest et nous
avons commencé donc notre périple de
deux
de dizaines d'heures en fait avant
d'arriver avant d'arriver au poste
frontière et en pologne vous parlez de
60 heures dans votre voiture avec votre
famille il y avait j'imagine beaucoup de
monde également sur la route qui
essayait de quitter de fuir qui a vous
avez vu beaucoup de personnes
oui bien sûr mon cas est très loin
d'être isolé c'est ce que beaucoup
d'ukrainiens malheureusement vivent
aujourd'hui c'est à dire
rester bloqué des dizaines d'heures à la
frontière ukraino polonaise dans sa
voiture
et donc on a été témoin de sa wii on a
vu effectivement énormément de gens
patienter alors énormément de familles
de femmes et d'enfants puisque beaucoup
d'hommes sont mobilisés en fait
aujourd'hui elles ne peuvent pas ne
peuvent pas quitter le pays bien sûr et
donc
donc c'est une situation qui est
effectivement très qui est dramatique et
et qui concerne essentiellement oui des
personnes vulnérables des femmes des
enfants des familles entières qui sont
parfois même obligé de se séparer
pour pour pouvoir se mettre à l'abri
est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles
régulièrement de ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de kiev j'imagine que vous
avez des familles peut-être encore de la
famille qui sont à kiev actuellement
c'est qu'il ya eu plusieurs explosions
cette nuit qui ont été entendus on sait
que l'étau se resserre autour de kiev
quelles sont les informations vous avez
j'ai pas une nouvelle fraîche ce matin
là en revanche si hier j'ai pas mal
communiqué avec des amis qui sont restés
en ukraine notamment à kiev
écoutez c'est très difficile de le
décrire tout ça parce que les
discussions qu'on a
avec mes amis restés rester sur place
sont parfois complètement surréaliste
hier une amie
professeur d'ukrainiens me disais que
enfin me disait carrément s'inquiète fac
elle avait annoncé qu'elle avait très
très peur qu'elle était cloîtré chez
elle avec des voisins depuis des jours
que les raids aériens les sirènes les
explosions et les combats sont des
choses effectivement très très
effrayante elle me demandait de de prier
pour elle elle m'a quasiment dit adieu
par par par message ccc
je ne sais pas comment je ne sais pas
comment vous décrire ce que ce que ça ce
que ça implique sur le plan
effectivement
psychologique émotionnel etc
c'est très compliqué après sur
comment dirais-je j'ai des amis aussi
qui ont pris les armes à kiev donc
notamment les amis de mon club de boxe
puisque je faisais de la boxe à kiev et
est donc j'étais en contact avec eux
hier aussi alors hier il me disait que
la situation à kiev pour eux étaient
plutôt calmes
lors à l'ordre pour les cités dans le
texte il me disait on a l'impression que
les russes sont en manque d'hommes
puisque
hier iny non il n'en voyait pas il n'y
avait pas de combat en tout cas pas
directement là où il était et j'ai
également donc des amis qui aide qui
sont à l'ouest de l'ukraine et qui
aident au ravitaillement des soldats
afin d'aider des volontaires qui ceux
qui ceux qui se battent contre 7 contre
cette invasion quand vous avez vous
voyez justement cette mobilisation
incroyable du peuple ukrainien cette
solidarité ça doit être très aisé
mouvement de voir à quel point perse
tout le monde est prêt à ne pas lâcher
écoutez c'est émouvant c'est sûr après
c'est pas étonnant pour moi parce que je
connais assez bien maintenant les
ukrainiens et je sais à quel point ils
sont capables de dans des circonstances
aussi particulière de 2,2 de s'unir et
de se battre et de se défendre pour leur
liberté
et
je pense qu'effectivement ça a été la
grosse erreur de jugement de deux de
plat d'hiver coutume dans cette histoire
c'est à dire que je pense qu'il qu'il
estimait que kiev pourrait être prise
rapidement que l'ukraine pourrait tomber
ou du moins une partie de l'ukraine
pourrait tomber rapidement et en fait ça
a été ça a été tout l' inverse puisque
vous savez on dit souvent que les élites
occidentales sont déconnectés parfois
des réalités du terrain mais je pense
que c'est valable aussi pour le kremlin
et pour ce que pour ce qui est de
vladimir poutine je pense qu'il était
complètement déconnecté des réalités
ukrainienne d'aujourd'hui poste meydan
poste 2014 et qu'il n'avait pas envisagé
que le peuple ukrainien pouvait être
aussi
unis et avide de liberté et ça
évidemment je je je trouve ça je trouve
ça très émouvant et je trouve ça un
problème les ukrainiens les habitants de
kiev s'était préparé dans un sens à
cette guerre comment était la vie à kiev
quelques jours avant le début de cette
invasion
c'est assez intéressant comme question
parce que si vous voulez on avait un peu
des sentiments contradictoires c'est à
dire que bon je vais parler de mon cas
encore une fois mais mais mais je pense
qu'il y avait pas mal d'ukrainiens danse
est dans cet état d'esprit là on n'y
croyait pas jusqu'à la fin on
n'envisageait pas du tout une invasion à
grande échelle comme ça de l'ukraine en
tout cas moi c'était pas du tout c'était
je n'aurais jamais pu imaginer ça
néanmoins on s'était quand même préparer
à des troubles
moi je pensais qu'il y aurait plutôt des
peut-être d une invasion enfin je veux
dire une
une reprise des combats par exemple à
l'est du pays qui entraînerait
éventuellement des troubles dans la
capitale peut-être des coupures
d'électricité un manque de nourriture
d'approvisionnement ce genre de choses
donc je mettais un petit peu préparé à
ça parce que ma femme est enceinte il
fallait absolument que je mette enfin
que je que je que je fasse en sorte
qu'elle est assez de nourriture d'eau de
médicaments etc
après l'ambiance honnêtement s'est
dégradé un peu à kiev je dirais deux
semaines avant l'invasion c'est encore
une fois assez difficile à décrire mais
j'ai senti une atmosphère il y avait une
atmosphère de tension une atmosphère
lourde quelque chose de das est
perceptible en fait quand vous quand
vous vous baladiez dans la rue ou que
vous faisiez vos activités quotidiennes
moins de monde - delà de la
préoccupation aussi enfin de l'anxiété
d'une certaine manière c'était c'était
une atmosphère lourde voilà volot dominé
les skis s'est posé en chef de guerre
ces messages réguliers aux ukrainiens
sur les réseaux sociaux le fait qu'il
soit resté aussi à kiev tout cela fait
du bien dans un sens si je puis dire au
au moral des ukrainiens il a su aussi
les mobiliser
énormément énormément je dois dire que
je suis extrêmement impressionné par
l'attitude de devolo dit marie céline ce
qui aujourd'hui sont son calme sa sa
détermination c'est quelque chose qui
effectivement bladi un rassure les
ukrainiens il ya des ukrainiens même je
lisais qui regardent ces vidéos pour ce
pour se calmer parfois pour faire
descendre un peu la pression parce qu'il
a cette faculté en tant que chef d'état
est aujourd'hui chef de guerre de 2,2 de
trouver les mots justes et d'avoir une
attitude qui rassure il a refusé de
quitter son pays il est déterminé à
rester à kiev jusqu'au jusqu'à la fin
c'est honnêtement vous savez comme moi
d'où vient zelensky
du showbiz de la télévision
et aujourd'hui on le voit dans un dans
un rôle qui n'est même plus un rôle en
fait puisque j'ai pas l'impression du
tout qu'il qu'il joue qu'il surjoue mais
on le voit réellement en chef d'état
déterminez calme et est extrêmement
rare weight que je je je je en tout cas
extrêmement inspirant
merci beaucoup pierre marescaux d'avoir
été avec nous on sait en vous disiez
vous attendez un heureux événement dans
toute cette horreur on vous souhaite
bien sûr plein de bonheur avec votre
femme et votre petite fille qui doit
arriver dans l'est dans les prochains
jours et merci encore d'avoir témoigné
sur notre antenne merci à vous est ce
qu'avec ton on se retrouve dans quelques
minutes pour la suite de paris direct
une nouvelle